[Musique]
bonjour nouvel entretien politique sur
tv 78 sur radio sensations aujourd'hui
laurent maurin et mon invité délégué
départemental du rassemblement national
dans les yvelines bonjour à vous bonjour
vous êtes à la fois tête de liste
yvelines aux régionales en ile-de-france
avec jordan bardella est également
candidat en binôme cette fois ci avec
monique foreurs moguérou au
départemental donc dans les yvelines sur
le canton de bonnières avant de parler
de ces deux scrutins plus globalement
aujourd'hui pour vous pour votre
formation est ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'être dans une bonne
dynamique dans le dans le département
pour les régionales et pour les
cantonales écoutez je crois que le
contexte effectivement social économique
sécuritaire et migratoire qui existent
aujourd'hui en france et donc aussi dans
les yvelines démontre que sur les
analyses les constats et les solutions
que nous faisons depuis de très
nombreuses années nous sommes pertinents
on va juste revenir sur les chiffres des
précédents scrutins en 2015 20% premier
tour 11,85 au second ça c'est pour les
départementales régionales 18 41
premiers tours 14,2 au second la
question elle est simple est-ce qu' il y
à une alliance nécessaire avec justement
des déçus des républicains avec
l'ensemble de la droite on l'a vu ces
dernières semaines jordan bardella un
fait des appels très nette aux électeurs
des républicains oui bah je crois que
les ralliements se font de manière
naturelle j'allais dire il n'y a pas
spécialement à forcer le destin
je pense que pour ne prendre qu'un
exemple
l'exemple du canton de venir sur lequel
je suis candidat avec monique fureur au
pérou
j'ai cru comprendre que un candidat de
l'équipe de pierre bédier donc des
républicains avaient été parachutées le
l'élu guy qui légitimement pouvait
aspirer à être à être le candidat et qui
ne l'a pas été cyril samson de bonnières
a dit clairement que c'était un candidat
hors sol patrick stefanini
il claquait la porte des républiques et
républicains pour cela et vous voyez
qu'à traverser ces événements nous
pouvons compter bien entendu sans doute
sur leur aliment naturel d'un certain
nombre d'électeurs des républicains que
ce soit sur ce canton que ce soit sur le
département dans dans sa globalité et
plus généralement sur la région ile de
france et même élargir encore un peu
plus puisque on voit ce qu'il se passe
notamment en région paca où des très
bons sondages se sont donnés pour
thierry mariani avec des dissensions
synthé républicain donc oui nous
appelons les électeurs les élus les
cadres et les militants républicains à
nous rejoindre
d'autant plus que nous nous rendons
compte également que aussi bien sur la
liste des élections régionales en île de
france que sur certains cantons des
yvelines pour les élections
départementales
les républicains sont ceux qu'on appelle
les républicains intègre un certain
nombre de candidats qui sont issus du
modem ou de la république en marche donc
les républicains aujourd'hui ne sont
plus les républicains ce sont les
républicains en marche et moi j'invite
effectivement les républicains sincères
les électeurs de droite à nous rejoindre
pour clarifier la situation parce qu'il
ne se ne peuvent plus se retrouver dans
un discours macro nist qui est porté par
leurs cadres
et on parle justement des propositions
vous avez mentionné ce canton de
bonnières où vous êtes présent donc en
binôme vous avez mentionné également la
majorité sortante avec patrick stefanini
et josette gens qui se présentent il a
également une liste lrmm et une liste de
gauche sur ce canton pour ses
propositions pour ce canton par vous
quelles sont vos propositions justement
parce que vous dénoncez vous dites à un
système en place
vous souhaitez mettre remettre de la
démocratie au delà de ça quelles sont
vos propositions concrètes pour ce
canton qui compte plus de plus de 60
communes non plus aoc est très vaste
oui c'est un canton très vaste retrait
rural avec beaucoup d'agriculteurs à
l'image un peu du département des
yvelines dont nous très clairement nos
propositions c'est d'abord que 5 euros
dépensés par le département le soient
dans l'intérêt des yvelinois et
uniquement dans l'intérêt des yvelinois
donc nous mettrons par exemple un terme
aux investissements qui ont été décidées
unilatéralement par pierre bédier et son
équipe en afrique dans le cadre de la
coopération internationale des
investissements qui sont avec qui sont
avec des résultats nuls avec une absence
de justificatifs une absence de factures
d'ailleurs la chambre régionale des
comptes épingle ses investissements pour
leur caractère opaque donc nous mettrons
un terme à cela nous mèneront également
une réflexion sur la pertinence du fonds
interdépartemental d'investissement qui
est là aussi a été mis en place par
pierre dédié qui est en fait un doublon
puisqu'il existe déjà une péréquation
horizontale entre les départements d'île
de france
il a décidé d'en faire un
supplémentaires qui coûte 32 millions de
roses et gris noir sans véritablement
retour et dont l'objet initial a été
détourné par ce que ce fonds était prévu
pour améliorer les transports
interdépartementaux mais finalement ils
sont ils existent pour financer des
collèges à l'autre bout de la région
ile-de-france compétence qui est
strictement réservé aux départements en
question donc on n'a pas nous yvelinois
à financer de collège ou de crèches dans
seine et marne par exemple donc voila
nous mèneront une réflexion sur la
pertinence de ce fonds interdit
d'interdire fortement talent pardon
d'investissement nous agirons bien sûr
en transparence à l'opal à l'opposé des
pratiques opaques de pierre bédier
je prends deux exemples tout d'abord
l'augmentation bien sûr dont tous les
yvelinois se souviennent de la part
départementale de la taxe foncière de 66
% décidée par pierre bédier en 2015 sans
aucune consultation bien sûr des
électeurs sans en avoir parlé pendant la
campagne de 2015
c'est une décision qui a été qui est
totalement injuste
fier en plus de ça sur d'un point de vue
d'un point de vue économique d'ailleurs
le département et chaque année en
excédent budgétaire très important ce
qui démontre bien par l'absurde que
cette augmentation massive des impôts
était était injustifiée je rappelle que
cette augmentation d'impôts a été
expliquée par l'augmentation de la
péréquation des départements les moins
riches conjuguée à une baisse de la
dotation aussi de l'état 1 ce qui est
expliqué et que et que entre temps il ya
eu également une baisse ensuite qui a
été qui a été voté oui alors
l'augmentation moi je ne remets pas en
cause le fait qu' il y ait eu une
augmentation je remets en cause le fait
qu'elle est été aussi massive et
qu'elles aient été effectuées sans en
parler aux électeurs lors de l'élection
départementale de 2015 qui s'était
déroulé juste avant cette prise de
décision
bien sûr que les dotations de l'état ont
diminué nous je le sais particulièrement
bien puisque en tant qu ancien premier
adjoint de la commune de mantes la ville
nous étions soumis aussi lcds de
dotation dont on comprend on peut
comprendre qu'effectivement une
augmentation de la taxe foncière et
était nécessaire mais certainement pas
dans l'ordre de grandeur de plus 60% qui
a été décidé c'est absolument
irraisonnables est exagéré je reviens
sur l'opacité des décisions de pierre
bédier de sa majorité
il y en a une autre qui a été prise
d'une autre décision c'est la fusion des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines
là encore sans consultation des
électeurs sans débat et nous vous
proposons
pourquoi pas de mettre en place un
référendum sur cette question alors j'ai
vu que pierre bédier ce que j'avais
c'est ce que j'allais souligné également
apparemment aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
vraiment d'actualité et vous évoquez une
fusion et un rapprochement entre les
deux départements sur des tâches et des
compétences très spécifiques
la fusion d'un n'avait pas encore été
actée en tout cas il y avait pierre
bédier avait aussi par l'éventuel manque
de consultation dont rien n'avait été
décidé encore sur cette question de
fusion la fusion n'avait effectivement
pas a été acté en tout cas par l'état
menée elle était bien engagée puisque
voilà il y avait déjà un organisme
préfigurateur de cette mutualisation des
départements pierre bédier annonce juste
avant les élections qu'il abandonne le
projet on peut douter de la sincérité de
cette annonce en tout cas nous très
clairement nous remettons en cause cette
décision nous proposerons pourquoi pas
un référendum sur cette question pour
consulter les électeurs sur des
décisions aussi importantes que cela
parce que cette fusion le remet en cause
les équilibres du gouvernement du talent
du département avec des investissements
qui qui se feront sans doute décider
beaucoup plus parlée au 100 et au regard
de la proportion de population beaucoup
plus importante dans les hauts-de-seine
que dans les yvelines
j'aimerais pour les minutes qui nous
reste nous parlions des régionales à
présent on a évoqué les départementales
rappelle que vous êtes responsable
départemental du rassemblement national
vous êtes candidat donc sur le canton de
beaune ya rassemblement national votre
formation qui présente des candidats sur
l'ensemble des cantons aussi parlons des
régionales à présent avec votre candidat
jordan bardella vous êtes tête de liste
l'une des compétences principales pour
la région s et les transports pour les
transports on estime à plus de 30 2
millions le nombre moyen de kilomètres
parcourus chaque jour sur les réseaux
routiers de la région
quelles propositions vous pouvez faire
pour désengorger les routes par exemple
écouter sur la thématique des transports
valérie pécresse en 2015 avait annoncé
qu'elle mettrait en place la révolution
des transports
bon je crois que les franciliens dans
leur globalité peuvent constater qu'il
n'y a pas eu de révolution des
transports 1
leyrit pécresse nous parle d'un certain
nombre
projet pharaonique comme le grand paris
express où le charles de gaulle express
qui doit relier le centre de paris à
l'aéroport charles de gaulle
mais en ce qui concerne la rénovation de
l'existant là il y a il ya effectivement
des manques et notamment par exemple sur
le rer b et sur le rer d donc nous notre
objectif c'est d'abord de concentrer nos
investissements
si nous sommes élus à la tête de la
région ile-de-france sur l'existant
l'existant en c'est à dire les rer les
rer b et également la mise en place d'un
grand chantier donc le doublement du
tunnel du châtelet qui favorisera la
multiplication des rer b et d et donc
fait il dira fluidifiera pardon les
transports afin de permettre aux usagers
de voyager dans de meilleures conditions
c'est un chantier très coûteux de
plusieurs milliards d'euros mais qui
devra associer plusieurs acteurs dont
l'état et je signale également que à
horizon 2030
valérie pécresse a créé une dette
colossale sur la compétence transport
une dette qui est estimée à environ 16
milliards d'euros
et on peut se demander pour quelles pour
quel gain pour les usagers puisque
chacun peut le voir au quotidien
il y a un problème avec la ponctualité
des trains
il y a des problèmes de conditions de
voyage et puis il ya surtout un problème
d'insécurité dans les transports et
c'est vrai que jordan bardella en fait
sa priorité
the show sur la sécurité spécifiquement
votre candidat propose de déployer deux
agents de sécurité armés dans chacune
des gares et les stations de métro
alors on rappelle que la sécurité c'est
pas forcément une compétence directe de
la région il faudra forcément engager
des discussions avec l'état sur ce sujet
là et puis il faudra également le le
financer il ya plus de 400 égard en ile
de france et je ne compte même pas les
métros oui bien sûr pas c'est un choix
politique c'est un choix politique de
répondre à une attente des franciliens
il se trouve que la région ile de france
concentre par un peu tous les problèmes
socio économiques de la france
c'est la première région économique est
bien entendue avec la multiplication des
événements violents un peu partout dans
le dans la région et dans le département
des yvelines notamment il est absolument
nécessaire est crucial d'investir sur la
sueur sur la sécurité vous avez
effectivement signaler que la sécurité
n'était pas une compétence de la région
c'est vrai mais il n'empêche que la
région peut quand même faire un certain
nombre de choses concernant donc la mise
en place de ces équipes de sécurité
concernant la vidéoprotection et je
dirais que de manière plus générale un
président de région et notamment la
région ile de france première région
économique de france en population
également qui concentre donc toutes les
thématiques économiques sécuritaires de
delà de la france je dirais que la
présidente de région n'est pas
uniquement là pour mettre en oeuvre les
compétences de la région
bien sûr que c'est une obligation bien
sûr qu'il faut le faire oui elle peut
pas être moi c'est non plus les
possibilités qui lui sont offertes dans
un cadre légal
non tous les ans vous les 16es conclure
par contre laurent parce que nous
aurions à la fin de cet entretien
donc juste sur cette cette compétence e
sécurité on l'a bien on vous a bien
entendu juste en un mot et je reviens un
peu sur les départementales aussi si
vous n'avez coite élu au conseil
départemental ce sera véritablement un
échec pour vous cette année c'est
l'ambition pas disons que de manière
générale la région ile de france et le
département des yvelines sont quand même
un territoire électoralement compliqué
pour nous ceci dit
accélération de la recomposition
politique les ralliements que nous
enregistrons la pertinence de nos
constats et de nos solutions dans
certains cantons des yvelines notamment
mantes la jolie mais bonnière les
mureaux et rambouillet où nous sommes
particulièrement fort en 2015 sur ces
cantons là nous faisions pratiquement
40%
je pense que nous pouvons envisager la
victoire sur ces cantons et si parra par
malheur effectivement n'arrivons à
remporter aucun canton sur les yvelines
je dirais que c'est presque voilà dans
la logique des choses dans un
département compliqué mais en tout cas
moi sur le canton de bonnières j'y vais
pour gagner je pense que le candidat
patrick stefanini est un candidat hors
sol c'est sans doute une erreur de
casting et nous allons mener une
campagne offensive
c'est dommage nous n'avons pas eu le
temps de parler et je vais devoir
justement vous vous interromps parce que
sinon on n'aura pas le temps dans le
cadre de cette émission diffusée sur tv
78 et sur radio sensations merci laurent
morin délégué départemental du
rassemblement national et candidat donc
aux régionales et aux départementales
dans les yvelines d'avoir été avec nous
on se retrouve l'inscrire sur tv 78
[Musique]